[Musique]
hier c'était la fête des mères
l'occasion pour Laeticia Hallyday de
rendre hommage à Jade et Joy s'effy
adoptive en postant plusieurs photos
d'elle accompagnées de ce message amour
éternel aux belles âmes qui ont fait de
moi une mère je vous aime comme je
respire mais alors que les deux jeunes
filles âgées de 14 et 18 ans qui compte
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'abonnés
sur Instagram avait déjà créé la
polémique en s'affichant sur les réseaux
sociaux
l'une des photos postées par Laetitia
Hallyday à cette fois était jugé
vulgaire par de nombreux internautes en
cause les tenues portées par les deux
sœurs juste pour info on peut être une
très jolie jeune femme sans avoir être
provocante alors comprenez-vous la
polémique
allô oui qui sait
alors
regardez alors regardez ce qu'on a pu
lire elles font vulgaire vos fils ont
vulgaires désolé mais mais je compte
du bon
goûts
de méchants qu'on lui fiche la paix elle
est avec ses deux filles elles sont
habillées
elles sont comme ça peut-être qu'il y en
a qui les trouve vulgaire peut-être
qu'il y en a qui les trouve sublime
voilà on les laisse avec quoi tout va
bien elle est avec ses fils et le
message était très joli le texte est
très très émouvant moi ça me dérange
vraiment pas du tout
oui il y en a marre de la police du
costume il y a des gens qui décident
comment il faut s'habiller ce qu'il faut
faire à quel moment de sa vie à quel âge
ils sont en famille elles ont les
épanouies elles jubilent lâchez-les un
peu quoi je trouve que oui regardez les
sourires je trouve vraiment que c'est
acharnement est totalement déplacé voilà
moi je leur dis bravo oui bonsoir les
filles sont les clichés de la
prostitution thaïlandaise donc là on est
même sur une pointe de racisme
il y a quelqu'un qui a dit ça donc
c'est-à-dire que en plus de juger de
jeunes filles qui s'habillent comme des
ados et voilà 18 ans 14 ans elles ont
pas non plus 8 ans et bien il le racisme
vient pointer le bout de son nez moi ça
me ça me dégoûte c'est dégueulasse ils
vont dire qu'ils ont acheté leurs
enfants
en fait je viens de parler mais c'était
pas très intéressant
je suis content
tiens voilà ah bah tiens non parce que
j'aide elle a 18 ans elle fait ce
qu'elle veut Joy à la 14 ans je suis
désolé
si elle est devant sa mère oui mais tu
veux que je te dise mais les mecs il y a
sa mère dis-moi ma fille elle a 12 ans
parfois elle est avec moi elle s'habille
et je dis ah ouais quand même tu vois
mais bon elle est avec son père de se
mettre en scène à moitié nu sur la
moitié de ses photos quand on a 14 ans
je suis désolé je pense que c'est
dangereux pour elle parce que ça plaît
peut-être
mais toi ton cul non mais excuse-moi sa
mère elle est là non mais c'est comme si
toi demain on vient s'occuper de tenir
pourquoi tu fais chier tes chiens dans
le canal dans le dans le salon je fais
ce que tu veux non franchement ah oui
non mais moi je déteste les donneurs de
pression que ma fille s'habille comme ça
à 14 ans justement
avec sa famille avec ses amis et écrire
des commentaires sous les photos il y a
vraiment un monde parce que là vous nous
demandez notre avis donc on est obligé
donc là Guillaume il est obligé de dire
bah ouais moi je suis contente parce
qu'on lui demande son avis j'ai compris
je suis désolé par contre elle est
harceler des gens des des petits jeunes
et aller écrire des commentaires sous
les photos et en plus tu m'as dit on
parle de racisme mais là c'est c'est
impardonnable bien sûr mais après si on
demande nous notre avis en plateau on
est obligé de le donner alors tu veux
que je te dise c'est quoi ton nom toi
tu as raison je suis une merde
[Rires]
parce qu'en fait je t'ai donné ton avis
est-ce que si tu avais mis un message
sur ton truc toi ton cul mais en fait
c'est moi qui me fait voilà
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi non mais déjà il y a raison
il y a des vieux pervers qui rôdent sur
les réseaux qui regardent des comptes de
fil de 14 ans et c'est pas bien et je
trouve que donner comme modèle à des
ados de 14 ans c'est quand même
extrêmement jeune elles sont mineurs que
de dire que de montrer ses formes de
s'exhiber de se montrer nu c'est de
manière d'attirer l'attention et de
générer l'attention oui ils font ce
qu'elle veut mais on a le droit de dire
que c'est pas mal s'habille comment mais
elles ont pas 14 ans
refait ta phrase avec ta meufs
avec moi
dans ton modèle à toi ça veut dire que
ce sont les femmes qui doivent
s'habituer au vieux pervers quand on est
une femme on doit s'habiller comme eux
c'est juste que tu dois pas anormaliser
le fait Daniel n'a pas d'enfants
comme les gens qui n'ont pas d'enfants
sont contre
moi
de 14 ans c'est bien ma fille montre tes
seins et mets des photos en crop top en
décolleté comme ça tu auras plus de
likes sur Instagram je trouve que c'est
une ce sont des valeurs déplorables
c'est peut-être pas ça chie hein
c'est choquant pas toi tu le regardes
son instincts
parce que moi j'ai des enfants et
quand je vois la gamine de 14 ans je me
dis elle elle est cadrée elle est à sa
maman c'est Laetitia et peut-être qu'il
y a une gamine de 13-12 ans qui va
vouloir sortir comme ça parce qu'elle a
vu ça elle aussi le modèle de la caisse
dans la gamine la caisse de résonance
elle aura peut-être pas le cadre de
Laetitia Hallyday dans les villages
peut-être elle sortira comme ça
leur demandez pas d'être des portes de
drapeau
une gamine de 12 ans on va dire moi
aussi je veux m'habiller comme elle et
je veux sortir comme ça pour aller
auprès d'unique de Romainville c'est pas
c'est pas pareil c'est pas la même vie
c'est d'accord c'est pas la même vie
quand même elle aussi les robes en or
moi je veux bien dans les soirées mais
là c'est la fête des mères
il y a une photo de gala regarde il y a
les plantes et tout c'est joli machin on
a sans jeunesse mais après tu as des
nanas peut-être de 12 ans qui vont dire
moi aussi ils peuvent faire comme je
vais mettre un sac
en tout cas je suis un combat
comment ça sérieusement quoi sur le
haricot